i don't think it is good for us
or for humanity to lose track of the
fact that in our finest moments
uh it is just the sheer joy of being
alive the spontaneous exuberance of
wallowing
in the mystery of life that i think is
what makes life most worthwhile but yeah
but it's also dreadful to be alive and
to know it because
unless you're a child or cognitively
impaired if you're smart enough to know
that you're here you're also smart
enough to know that like all living
things
you two will someday die and ernest
becker's point is that that unwelcome
realization
the the worm at the core of the human
experience as william
james put it that that was the most
significant
psychodynamic event in the history of
the human species
are we gonna talk about death today
um i believe that we will uh hopefully
not
for the sake of death per se but in the
interest
of enhancing life how does death enhance
life
well at our best the existentialists
tell us since time immemorial um it is
necessary
to come to terms with
the most basic fact of human existence
and that is that
look that we like all living creatures
are are of finite duration and
um theologians philosophers you know
people just sitting on a rock
back in the in antiquity have
wrestled frankly uh with this idea
um you know every other form of life is
unperturbed uh by the reality
that a finitude
but we necessarily are and
the claim very simply is that whether
we're aware of it or not
death anxiety um pervades every aspect
of our existence and malignant
manifestations of death anxiety
are arguably responsible directly or
indirectly for a considerable
proportion of human foibles and
so the claim is that both for the
benefit of ourselves
as individuals to to get the most out of
life
as well as for the benefit of society in
general
yeah it is necessary both individually
and collectively to come to terms with
our mortality
what are some of the manifestations of
how they can malignantly manifest
yes so so great question i'll back up a
little bit just to give folks
um some detail that the work that we do
um is derived from a cultural
anthropologist ernest becker who in the
1970s
uh won a pulitzer prize for a book
called the denial of death
and what becker argued
you know very simply is that um
yeah humans are like all other living
things
uh you know darwinian wise that
uh we are biologically predisposed
to want to survive in the interests of
self-preservation and
and for reproduction um and yet
uh we're different than other creatures
and without being overly
arrogant the claim is that our huge
forebrain
gives us the capacity to think
abstractly and symbolically
uh to the point where we can even
imagine stuff that doesn't yet exist
and then have the audacity to take our
dreams and render them real
and that could not be more uplifting to
me
um i like otto ronk you know freud's boy
who said humans make the unreal real
and we don't want to lose track of the
fact that all
other creatures have to accept the world
in the form in which they
encounter it you know i get it spiders
make webs
beavers make dams bees make hives
and they've been doing it quite well for
hundreds of millions of years
yeah but they don't imagine a flying
machine like da vinci
you know in the 1500s or 1400s or and
then actually you know centuries later
were flying around
in what was originated in somebody's
imagination
all right all great so far uh until and
still great
um when when but ernest becker says
okay uh let's now move to kierkegaard
the danish existential philosopher who
said you know
people are so smart that we realize that
we're here
and uh and of course humans
we take this for granted you know you
wake up every day and you're like here i
am i woke up or you know you're walking
down the street you're like here i am
walking down the street
or it can get even crazier than that
here i am walking down the street
thinking about that i'm walking down the
street so uh
it you know you could be wow now i'm
thinking about that i'm thinking about
that i'm walking down the street until
you have to turn into the nearest pub to
extricate yourself
from this perseverating cycle of
annoying
self-focus well so what you know
kierkegaard said
you know if you're smart enough to know
that you're here
which he insisted requires a
sophisticated cognitive apparatus to
render yourself the object of your own
subjective inquiry
then you're going to experience two
uniquely human emotions
aw and dread and kierkegaard's like
wait a minute it's awesome to be alive
and to know it
that that's just great that's why if you
get to choose between being a person and
a potato
or a person on a potted plant you make
your own choice
but i i want to be i want to be a person
and so like that that is awesome and i
always
want to emphasize just to cheer myself
up and also to make an important point
all silliness aside
i i don't think uh it is good for
us or for humanity uh to lose track
of the fact that in our finest moments
uh it is just the sheer joy of being
alive
the spontaneous exuberance of wallowing
in just the mystery of life that i think
is
what makes life most worthwhile
but kierkegaard says yeah but it's also
dreadful
to be alive and to know it uh because
um unless you're a child or cognitively
impaired if you're smart enough to know
that you're here you're also smart
enough to know that like all living
things you two will someday die
and ernest becker's point is that that
unwelcome realization
the the worm at the core of the human
experience as william
james put it that that was the most
significant
psychodynamic event in the history of
the human species
it was a quite unintended byproduct
of consciousness which is otherwise you
know quite frankly
tremendously uplifting and adaptive
but it doesn't end there so uh you know
psychological kick in the groin number
one is uh you're gonna die
someday uh number two um
is that not only will you die someday
but you can die at any time for reasons
that you could never anticipate or
control
it'd be bad enough if i knew i was gonna
die you know in some vaguely unspecified
future moment with all of my friends and
family
you know linked arm and arm chanting
kumbaya
into the afterlife that will be maybe
okay
but i know i can walk outside and get
smote by a comic
a comet or a pandemic and
then on top of that uh becker says wow
uh humans we don't welcome the idea that
we're going to die
and we certainly are discombobulated by
the fact that
death is always potentially imminent
and then on top of all of that uh
borrowing from freud
we chafe at the idea that we're embodied
animals
uh respiring pieces of defecating meat
no more significant or enduring
than barnacles or armadillos and
all that becker says is look if that's
the only thing
that you were thinking about you know
i'm gonna die someday
uh i could get hit by a comet you know
i'm a breathing
piece of me you you would
not be able to stand up in the morning
you would be crippled by
overwhelming existential terror that
according to becker human beings
manage uh by embracing what he calls
cultural world views
humanly constructed beliefs about
reality
uh that we share with the people in our
group
uh that reduces death anxiety by giving
us
a sense that life has meaning and we
have value
and basically um that's the essence
of becker's um
way of thinking about things we're smart
enough to know that we're here
uh that makes us aware of the fact that
we are finite and vulnerable embodied
creatures
uh that raises the possibility of
being flattened by debilitating terror
that
we manage uh by by by
embracing a belief system that allows us
to
feel like life has meaning and we have
value and
moreover if you're lucky enough to
believe that you're a person of value in
a world of meaning that's what becker
calls self-esteem
and then he says well uh that whether
we're aware of it or not
we spend most of our waking moments
and perhaps many of our dreaming ones
trying to maintain
confidence in our cultural world views
and a sense that we are people of value
in the context of them all right having
said all of that chris now back to your
fine
question which is okay let's now think
about
the implications of that fact
for non-optimal outcomes
because what a lot of people said to
becker is well look
so what you know let's say that you're
right uh
my beliefs about reality uh serve
to diminish death anxiety and it does so
by
making me feel like life has meaning
and i have value
well uh you know if it's not broke don't
fix it
you know some people just said well
maybe that's
that's what's happening but to which
becker replies um yes
um that is what's happening and we now
need to consider
some of the uh less than
desirable uh outcomes as a result and so
for
example um where we got interested
in these ideas chris my buddies jeff
greenberg and tom pozinski and i
uh we've spent almost the last 40 years
we're egghead
experimental psychologists and so uh
becker you know writes this book he gets
a pulitzer prize
he couldn't get a job when he was alive
and we couldn't get any of these ideas
published when we first were attracted
to them in the 1980s because people said
there's no
evidence for any of these ideas
nor is it possible to collect any
evidence and so
we're like okay let's see if we can do
that
and what we were interested in at the
time was how come people can't get along
with other people
who don't share their beliefs in reality
you know why is it
that since minute one
you know uh if you even the most benign
uh look at human history uh reveals
what i think is a grotesque and ugly
picture an ongoing succession of
genocidal atrocities
juxtaposed with the brutal subjugation
of designated in-house inferiors
and um and and we are now at the point
in human history where of course uh is
cliche but we possess the kind of
weapons that could reduce
the earth to rubble and so
this long-standing problem is robert j
lifton a psycho historian who i'm fond
of in a book called destroying the world
to save it
he's like wow we may be the first form
of life to be responsible
for our own extinction because of our
inability to get along with folks who
are different than ourselves
and becker's account is disarmingly
simple
and he has two points one is he says
well
if my beliefs about reality help me
reduce death anxiety
then whenever i run into somebody who's
different
i've got a problem whether i'm aware of
it or not if i believe
god created the earth in six days and
then
i run into somebody in the fulani tribe
in mali
and they think that the earth was
created out of a giant
drop of milk well if they're right
then i've got to be wrong and so
one point that becker makes is that the
mere existence of people with
alternative
belief systems is fundamentally
threatening
right so that's point number one i point
number two
in a book called escape from evil which
is
after the denial of death uh becker says
here's the other problem
our culturally constructed beliefs are
very potent
but they're still symbolic whereas death
is a very
real biological fact and
there's no symbol that is potent enough
to completely eliminate death anxiety
therefore in psychobabble there's
residual
anxiety that is repressed and i love
becker's language he says look there's
going to be death anxiety there's going
to be a
panic rumbling beneath the surface of
consciousness
and and that panic is so unpleasant
that what we do psychodynamically is we
project it
and we we basically lay it on to
other people or groups of people that we
just declare to be the all-encompassing
repositories of evil
and and so the point here is that
even if there weren't people who were
different around we would create those
differences we would need to virginia
woolf
in a room of uh wanzone she just says if
necessary
we'll hate somebody for the shape of
their nose
and for the color of their shirt because
we can't help it we've got to have a way
of offloading our insecurities right
either way what becker argues is that
what we do when we bump into folks who
are different
or declare people to be different is
we denigrate them uh we badger them
to abandon their beliefs and
adopt ours instead or or we just kill
them
thus demonstrating the superiority of
our beliefs after all
and our experiments show that this is
very much the case so our studies are
very simple uh they involve uh
reminding some people that they're gonna
die and other people
uh are asked to think about something
unpleasant but not fatal well like
you're getting a root canal
without anesthetic you've been in a car
accident and they have to chop off one
of your legs all painful
but beats being dead and sometimes we
remind people they're gonna die
by stopping them outdoors in front of a
funeral parlor as opposed to a hundred
meters
on either side yeah that's a good one
and sometimes
we bring people into the lab and we have
them read stuff on the computer
while we flash the word death for 48
milliseconds so fast that you can't see
anything
and so when we do that what we find
for example is that if you remind
christians that they're going to die
they love christians more and they hate
jewish people
and it has nothing to do with
christianity if you remind israelis that
they're going to die
they love israelis and they
hate arabs and ditto all over the world
but it's not only about attitudes
germans reminded that they're going to
die
they sit closer to people who look
german further away from
people who look like immigrants um you
remind
iranians that they're gonna die and they
become
more willing to uh blow themselves up
they become more willing to become
suicide bombers you remind americans
they're gonna die
and they become more supportive of using
uh
biological chemical and nuclear weapons
against countries who pose
no direct threat to us right so one
malignant manifestation
of death anxiety is that it
increases it amplifies the hostility and
disdain
uh that we have towards people
who are different and if i can remember
it i
always loved george bernard shaw on your
side of the pond a century ago
and a heartbreak house one of my
favorite plays he says
uh when the angel of death sounds his
trumpet the pretenses of civilization
are blown from men's heads into the mud
like hats in a gust of wind
so that's one possibility i can babble
about a few more i will and then you
shut me off but anyway another thing
that we are really interested in and i
think is very pertinent right now both
here
and on your side of the world is the
extent to which
existential anxieties uh impel
us to embrace certain kinds of political
leaders
max weber dead german sociologists at
the beginning of the 20th century he
said in times of historical upheaval
uh when existential uncertainties are
apt to prevail
that people are prone uh to become
attached to
and supportive of a particular kind of
leader uh he coined the term charismatic
that we're now
all familiar with seemingly
larger-than-life individuals that are
often believed to be divinely ordained
to rid the world of evil
and becker uses
uh weber's analysis to understand how
hitler came to power
uh in germany uh you know the germans
had been humiliated
um after world war one the economy was
decimated and here comes hitler saying
i can make germany great again only
i can do it and he gave
the germans it was a tremendously
uplifting
psychological vote of confidence to
restore
up meaning and value in
a very psychologically tenuous time and
i'm not saying that this ended well the
in fact the point is
that it rarely does we became interested
in this in the aftermath of september
11th
2001 when president george w bush
in a three-week period went from having
the lowest
support in the history of presidential
pollings
to three weeks after 9 11 he had the
highest
and we're like wow maybe um
maybe intimations of mortality had
something to do with it maybe september
11th was like a
giant death reminder of course it was
you had the people
dying and jumping off the world trade
center
uh terrorists are evil but they choose
their targets wisely
they didn't target random buildings they
targeted the pentagon symbol
and the world trade center that's right
and they did it with airplanes from
american
and united airlines or u.s air they knew
uh what they were doing and so we did a
lot of studies
prior to the 2004 election where we
showed that reminding
people of death increased their support
for president bush and in fact
in the absence of a death reminder our
participants liked
senator john kerry who was the
democratic challenger in that election
much more than president bush all right
so fast forward to 2015
uh we got donald trump uh saying
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna make america
great again uh i am
the only one that can keep you
safe from the rapists and the drug
dealers the negrotimist hordes storming
the borders
uh the terrorists that are parachuting
into america to rape our daughters and
eat our chicken wings and the chinese
uh that are threatening our economy
uh and uh and um it worked and
so uh president trump now president
trump uh despite the fact that
in the eyes of more than 60 million
americans
they're like wait a minute um it's
really a bad idea to have a vulgar
sadistic
vindictive pathologically narcissistic
sociopathic racist
xenophobic misogynistic homophobic
functionally illiterate twittering
mussolini
[ __ ] grabbing cheese doodle
impersonator that would be a bad idea
uh to have someone like that uh in
office
and uh moreover psychiatrists and
psychologists said
it's really a bad idea to that that
that now president trump has a unique
combination
of toxic psychological disorders that
being malignant narcissism sociopathy
uh lack of empathy touch of paranoia
when you have somebody with a massive
ego
who is congenitally incapable of ever
admitting that they're wrong
that's going to be a problem
particularly if
any crisis arises because there's no way
a person with that
particular set of affectations will be
capable of
acting in anyone's interest but their
own all right
be that as it may we then did studies
um that demonstrated the same thing uh
specifically uh that in america
support for president trump is magnified
uh by intimations of mortality
uh in a controlled condition uh
americans liked
hillary clinton more than they did
donald trump but if they were reminded
of their mortality first
they now like donald trump a lot more
so that's another area where death
anxiety
has potent effects that i believe
to have serious implications
for the future of democracy and this is
not only on the u.s
side of things i think a lot of the
things that are happening uh in the uk
um uh you know to be silly and at the
risk of annoying people we have orange
hitler over here you've got yellow
hitler
and there's a bunch of other uh hitler's
uh
you know right-wing populist movements
that
parlay death anxiety uh into
support because it is well known a woman
i like hannah arendt
in a book called the origin of
totalitarianism
uh after written in the 1950s
she just points out that um you know
it's pretty much the same playbook
another guy i like a lot eric hoffer
wrote a book called the true believer
and what all these kind of leaders do
they're like alchemists of hate they
they
are very good at a ketoing
existential anxieties they convert fear
into hate
because they take the internal anxiety
and they tell their followers who it is
that
they're supposed to hate anyway that
doesn't bode well for democracy
another area of inquiry is
just studies that show that death
anxiety makes us uncomfortable
with the fact that we're embodied
animals
makes us uncomfortable with nature makes
us more likely
uh to uh to to engage in
behaviors vis-a-vis nature that
undermine
uh the preservation of non-renewable
resources and so
uh basically death anxiety has
demonstrably
negative effects on environmental
concerns
it has the opposite effect on our
seeming
insatiable desire for money and stuff
and so on the one hand when death is on
our minds
uh it really makes us distance ourselves
from nature on the other hand
when death is on our minds it makes us
run to the television to the pub
and to the shopping mall um
and um and this is an idea
that also goes back uh uh
quite a bit uh in fact uh who's it john
locke in his second treatise
on government that was at 1690
he said look anything that really
matters
anything that is real there's an
upper limit to how much you can want
and and so and and he explained that he
said that's because anything in nature
is of finite duration
so if you like apples well that's great
but after like 10 apples you're like oh
i've had enough
all right but but and if you like pizza
all right i've had uh you know whole
pizza that's enough i like beer
after eight pints no maybe ten that's
that's enough
you know just fill in the blank well but
what's the one thing that people
can't get enough of well there's never
enough
money and there's never enough stupid
[ __ ] if you'll
pardon the expression a consumer society
would collapse
in a matter of hours if people bought
only
what they genuinely needed so anyway
what becker says is look whenever
there's insatiable desires
you can assume that death anxiety
underlies them
and sure enough if we remind people
they're going to die
they say they need more money to feel
wealthy
they're more eager to buy things that
are luxury items they'll even pay more
money to have a star
named after them uh in the galaxy
and then i'll say one more thing and
then back to you chris and i appreciate
the time just to build these out because
i do think that one of the things that
is i find compelling about these
ideas is how pervasive
they apply to a range of superficially
disparate human affectations the idea
that death anxiety influences you know
who you
hate who you voted for
how you feel about being outside and so
on
whether or not you like a certain kind
of car
i find that quite astonishing but the
last thing
that that i would note is just that
death anxiety amplifies all existing
forms of psychological disorders and
uh so if you're depressed and you're
reminded of death you become more
depressed if you're afraid of spiders
you become
more afraid of spiders and
and and so on and so forth and so
yeah the basic argument here you know
and it sounds
kind of corny but when we write about
this we we use a phrase from a guy a
british author i like thomas hardy a
novelist who says if a way to the better
there be
it comes from taking a close look at the
worst
and you know that is uh humanity
at its worst right hateful
proto-fascists uh you know kind of
uh raping the earth in
our effort to maximize the accumulation
you know of money and stuff in a
perpetual
uh you know alcohol pill infused
facebook twittering stupor and so that's
that's not great of course and
but it doesn't follow from that you know
just getting back to where we started
the conversation
uh that it doesn't follow from that that
we can't use these same ideas
uh more productively because i think
what we have to note is that
everything that i've talked about so far
is is in response to really subtle
even unconscious reminders of death
and so when you ask me when we began to
talk a half an hour ago when you said
all right you know what is why is it so
important
that we come to terms with death i like
albert camus come to terms with death
thereafter anything is possible
um this is really a plea
to not leave our death anxiety buried
under the psychological bushes you know
where it comes back to bear bitter
fruit this is rather a plea
you know not to wallow in concerns about
mortality that's not the point if you
want to do that you start a goth
punk rock band and that might be pretty
good
but rather you know to courageously
and and uh you know with diligence
to embrace the lifelong task
of coming to terms with the reality of
death
uh in a very self-conscious way
because that can produce outcomes that
are of a distinctly more
favorable kind dude i love that
i absolutely love that
i've got a million different doorways to
hell opening my mind at the moment so
i'm going to try and close a couple of
them
one of the questions i had was you
mentioned that
the denial of death is innate
and is essentially fixed by culture or
one of the particular tools we use to
try and dampen that down is culture
presumably evolutionarily our
current brain manifestation and thus
awareness of death
would have arisen before we had culture
to be able to deal with it
what do you think ancient man
would have done yeah wow
all right uh chris i uh i'm sorry we
lost our
video so i can't smile at you that's
like an awesome question
and if i could answer that uh you know
i'd be
chugging grum uh in a coconut with my
nobel prize
on the beach no that um because
as a lot of folks have noted um
as we have pondered uh for quite some
time uh you know the the apes and the
chimps
from which uh we presumably evolved
you know are unaware of death and and
don't appear thereby
to deny it we most assuredly
are and you're raising an important
question which is phylogenetically
how did that happen and um
the argument that we make and
this is necessarily speculative of
course but there are other scholars who
have independently come up with
similar ones the argument is
that humans were
almost certainly back in the day
engaged in ritualistic
behavior of a
religious nature oh and this is long
before of the awareness of death arose
even if it was uh vague and it's long
before
even gods arose so emil durkheim a
french sociologist
he points out david sloane wilson who's
a
an evolutionary biologist they argue
that that
that religion arose basically a social
glue
a a way to foster social cohesion and
coordination
sorry to interject there sheldon what's
the latin word for religion is it
reg regal or regard you know i i should
have looked that up yeah
it means to buy combined yeah that's it
work to tie
yes so social glue is a very apt term
for it yeah
no thanks chris and please jump in here
because i do think that this is
important the the idea
is that you know we are uber social
creatures
and and and for durkheim
that there's an emotional component to
this
binding he just said that there is
something
tremendously uplifting about being in
the company
of our fellow humans in
moments that can only be described as
you know just ones that are are
they are described as moments of like
transcendental joy
um we're you know you're back in the day
it's a beautiful day the hunt has gone
well
life is good everybody's hanging around
and there's just this collective
effervescence which for durkheim has a
lot to do uh with what
underlies the appeal of religion but
anyway back to our story the
the argument is that there already was
uh a primitive in the non-pejorative
sense
early forms of ritualistic behavior
that served a religious function and
this is before
uh the origin of the mythical narratives
that eventually came to correspond to
the behavior
and so the argument is that the rituals
came first
and then uh the narrative account of why
we're engaged in them came subsequently
and one possibility is that all of this
is happening
while human beings are reaching
a threshold of self-awareness
both nietzsche as well as otto ronk
probably
based on nietzsche uh they hypothesized
that self-awareness just kind of
gradually
increased but then it gets to a a point
where there's kind of a tipping point
where you become explicitly aware
of the prospect of mortality at which
point
the argument is that uh different
there were probably different
mythological
accounts of the world that
existed at the time and that just
through the process of natural selection
uh that the ones that tended to offer
existential comfort uh in the form
of promises of either literal or
symbolic immortality uh were probably
those
that were most appealing and therefore
persisted over time
so i don't know if that makes any sense
absolutely
absolutely does um do you think oh god
man
sheldon i've got i've got about 50
questions that i need to ask ask at the
same time
um first one is that tipping point
or stepping out of the bicameral mind
and into something above that
yes right that's that's that's what i
wanted to know um
absolutely and this uh so you you know
the julian jane
stuff no please don't oh so you said by
caramel mine this is awesome i'm
enjoying this immensely
although selfishly it's not about me
being entertained chris but
there's a guy in 1975 you're too young
uh
julian james the origin of consciousness
and the breakdown of the bicameral mind
and so to answer your question and
that's one of my favorite books and i
how i got interested in this
uh because jane's point is that
for much of human history we were
kind of automatons uh
and that it's only recently uh that
we've gotten into full death denial mode
and that is a reflection of the
breakdown of the bicameral mind
leaving us starkly aware
of the reality of our condition that's
why nietzsche said that consciousness
is the most calamitous stupidity by
which we shall someday perish or perish
someday
that's a beautiful quote yeah you it's
really interesting
to think about what it would have been
like to not
know that you well i mean you're
technically not your own thoughts but
you're at least aware that they're
coming from somewhere within you as
opposed to being bestowed on you by a
god
someone who's essentially sort of
speaking words in your ear um
yeah that i mean whoever the first human
was
that decided to cross whatever threshold
of consciousness it is that's a
it's a very uncomfortable frontier to be
the first person to get
absolutely no absolutely christian i
wish i had the skills to
like do science fiction because you know
the argument and i think it's quite
plausible is it might have happened
a [ __ ] ton of times over history
you know so imagine you're the one
self-aware
person you know in antiquity it must
have been
quite a ride yeah definitely would have
been no one else would have been able to
understand you
that's correct right next question is
what actually i'm gonna i'm gonna
diverge again and just open up another
branch
what is your view i know you're not an
evolutionary psychologist an
evolutionary biologist but i'm going to
ask you it anyway
what is your view of the reason why
consciousness exists
well yeah again another nobel prize
winning one
yeah i'm happy to talk again if you want
to save the trivial pursuit
next time around
you know always depends on who you ask
you know the uh and
you know so stephen panker you know
harvard smart guy
he said the problem of consciousness is
the central issue
of uh you know psychological discourse
for the 21st century
and he's probably right um
and um and so as you know there's some
people
who think that consciousness is epi
phenomenal
it's just really like an ethereal mist
given off as an irrelevant afterthought
it's just a byproduct
of other processes
and um i find that extraordinarily
unconvincing uh for a variety of reasons
and even folks uh like um
oh selfish gene richard dawkins
he writes in the 1970s that he finds it
inconceivable
that consciousness uh has
no functional value nicholas humphrey
who's a
british guy he wrote a book called
consciousness regained i think in the
1980s
and um i favor his view
which is that consciousness may have
evolved
um in social settings that it's not
actually an individual psychological
attribute
but rather that in a complex
setting um knowing how
you're feeling was probably a good way
to figure out
how other people are feeling
and being able to know that that's like
theory of mind in
psychobabble makes it so much easier to
negotiate your relationships with fellow
human
beings and so one possibility
is that consciousness arose
um in order to facilitate
social interaction and isn't it
interesting that one of the common
threads that we've gone through today
and this is
this ties really nicely back to a
question to do with death that's been
sort of lurking in the back of my head
since he started talking
death is inherently an individual
phenomenon i know that we're all going
to die
but the right fear of death is something
that we all a burden that we all bear
on our own and yet for some reason
our favorite antidote to this particular
fear of death
is to tribalize is to somehow
use other people that are the us and
other people also the other them
to try and fix a problem which is
inherently individualistic
and what we found again here there's a a
couple of other interesting
theories of consciousness is reason for
being here that i've stumbled upon
recently that i really enjoy
but that one the one that you've just
proposed there which you
think you've got a fair bit of support
for which again
is that humans have this conscious
process
so that we can better understand what
other people are thinking it means we
can
either deceive or cooperate or do a
million other things with them
more accurately like it's right it's so
i find it so interesting um perhaps it's
particularly fascinating because i'm an
only child that
our most important elements
perhaps the thing which underlies what
you're proposing
underlies all of our behavior
and the thing which facilitates that
underlying being made conscious
both of those things have an inherently
social
aspect to them yes oh
again i it really well put
and really in my estimation
important and in in also in my
estimation chris it counts for a lot of
the difficulties
that i find we're now having uh
in the world uh in in terms of
of just political difficulties
but i don't mean this to i don't mean
this as a political diatribe but
it's ironic is it not that the us
and the uk are the most individualistic
cultures in the history of earth we're
the richest and most technologically
adroit uh for the moment
um and in part because you know we've
got this john locke idea that there's no
such thing as society
that there's just individuals
and that's quite psychotic
it's never been true and yet we carry on
as if it is
but when in fact as you noted our entire
evolutionary past is based on our uber
social nature ultimately in the service
of fostering cooperation
right i can see that i can in a in a
modern society that's
hyper convenient and where we feel
incredibly detached from our own animal
nature and from the natural world
at large yeah i can see i'm a
red-blooded meritocracy loving
capitalist through and through
as mu as much as it can get um
and yet i can also say i i understand
why people don't have this sense of
connectedness
to a wider and i also mentioned as i
said only child which
gives you a particularly unique view on
solitude
i think yes um so yeah i i get it
you know i see why the meritocratic
21st century hyper convenient detached
from the natural world
world view that viewpoint i understand
how it can create that
yes oh and but i just to put in a caveat
i share your view
in principle i i i believe in
meritocracy and
individual initiative embedded in a
communal setting with the stipulation
that in principle there's enough to go
around so that anybody who exerted
sufficient effort
would have a reasonable chance of
uh there being a decent outcome and
you know that's where the proverbial
devils in the details
um but anyway yes very good point cool
um next thing i'm still closing doors to
hell oh by the way sheldon have you got
when's your next appointment
or what else have you got on today oh
it's 2 15.
and again i'm happy to talk again if you
find it
uh i don't know what time it is for you
what time is it now 10 oh i'm sorry
i'm at 151 i've got let's say 20 minutes
or so
cool right i am going to i mean move on
um
what do you think happens if we defeat
death one day
have you considered that i had david
pierce one of the foremost thinkers
behind the transhumanism movement on
he's talking about extending life
whether we have whole brain emulation
integrating with machines we use
pharmaceuticals to extend our life we do
all sorts of other different things
what happens if we defeat death one day
yeah great again another great question
um it's one that goes back uh
to antiquity uh you know the in uh
ancient greeks the gods were
immortal and their lives were
miserable and banal and
one philosophical notion is
that it would be terrible
uh to live in a world of
where one existed in perpetuity i i like
a
american philosopher martha nussbaum who
just points out
if if there was no such thing as death
then the very meaning of something being
meaningful becomes meaningless
you know there there's nothing
consequential what does it mean to say
somebody has
courage or somebody's generous um if
uh if if like a video game uh
you know if something bad happens you
just
re-up your avatar and hit the trail
again
so that's one possibility is that it
would be boring
to a degree uh that
would make most uh legal tomes seem
uplifting by comparison another
possibility
is that and this is one that ernest
becker considers in the denial of death
is that rather counter-intuitively
it might make us more anxious
um and his his argument is by example he
just says well
let's say that you're climbing up a
mountain you're 10 years old and your
life expectancy is
80 years and you fall into the bottom of
the grand canyon and you die
well that's a downer because you just
lost 70 years of life
now let's say you're climbing up a
mountain and you expect to live half a
million years or forever
and you fall down the mountain and his
point is is you can banish
death but you can never banish chance uh
you don't know that
you're gonna you might get smote by a
comet and your body might be vaporized
you don't know that maybe you've
abandoned your body
and you put yourself on a cloud
somewhere
yeah but when the power goes down um
there's not going to be any cloud in
other words you can banish death but you
can't banish
chance and therefore becker argues
that death anxiety might increase
and our defensive reactions therefore or
thereafter
might also increase commensurately
yeah that would be that would be an
awful side effect
right guys we can live forever but we're
all going to be so
unbelievably afraid that we're not we're
not prepared
to do anything because the potential
downside
of it the asymmetry starts to
to lean i suppose that you know the
the the nice thing about only living 80
years is if you
you know die before you've reached
middle age you're kind of 35.
well i need to get 50 of the way there
like it's not that long
so yeah bizarrely our short lives
actually assuage the fear of death
to some some way or another which is
which is very interesting
what insight about our minds do you wish
more people knew
oh wow
oh what a disarmingly
great question sheldon you just continue
with the flattery today
in fact if i can if i can bring you one
to just flatten me during
other episodes with you know if your
guests being difficult and you can just
say something nice about me that would
be
that would be funny no you know i i mean
this sincerely and you can edit it out
chris i i'm i'm not any
uh world famous entity and i do talk to
a lot of people
and it's often excruciating and this has
been just
delightful uh uh honestly so uh um
all right so back to the the mind
um what okay what insights do you wish
that one insight
would be to uh please abandon
the uh your affection for whether you're
aware
aware of it or not the
cartesian dualism that pervades western
society
that sees the mind and the body as
uh separate and disso dissociated either
in principle or in practice so
i would urge people to put the mind back
in their brain
and back in their body and
to to view ourselves more holistically
not as minds that happen to be situated
in a physical carcass but rather to view
ourselves as
physical carcasses that happen to be
lucky enough to be imbued with a kind of
mindedness
that is a fantastic opportunity
to have a great life and
even make the world a bit better in the
process of living it so that would be
one thing
i would i i say some of these things
chris to remind myself
and another thing i i would say
at the risk of maybe sounding a little
silly
is that um people
no this is not silly i mean this
earnestly there's a wide body of
research
that suggests that a lot of people see
a phenomenon associated with mind as
essential in the sense that you're born
with a mind you have certain capacities
and that's all there is
to it and the fact of the matter is is
that even
viewing our minds that way lobotomizes
us
um we should view the mind more as
a muscle uh that uh can be used in a
variety of ways and
can be developed over time vis-a-vis
effort this doesn't mean we can all be
einstein or beethoven
but we can all be a
a lot more uh who we are destined to
become then we give ourselves
credit for and my last
piece of advice is that you don't have
to be
great at everything so i put in a plea
for the average and
the mundane um you know we i think we
tend to think oh i have a mind so i got
to write a novel i got to get a nobel
prize
um and those things are good but so is
being a decent human
enjoying the fact that you happen to be
alive on a beautiful day when you've had
enough to eat and a place to stay
and so i think the mind can be deployed
for a much wider
variety of essential functions tied to
intellect emotion and intuition than we
often give it credit for
i love that i love that so i'm going to
give you a thought experiment to do
have you seen the film mother
i have not although it's on my list cool
you do you know the premise
no i don't okay so um a baby is born
inside of a factory
where it is raised by a robot
and then later on some some
complications happen i won't spoil it
for you
um my end goal question is is there a me
outside of my cultural influence
and the thought experiment is a baby is
born
we have managed to come up with a very
very clever way to program a robot
to be able to keep said human alive
right whilst not or whilst minimizing
or if possible giving zero cultural
influences
what would that person be like
wow awesome uh
yeah go get your nobel prize for
question asking
all right depe all right depends who you
ask so again uh uh
agnostic on this these are like the
questions of my youth
when we dabbled far too often in
hallucinogens i love thinking about
because you know so you got to you got
like the nietzsche
or even john locke blank slate yeah but
which is that you would be
not much different than a respiring
pincushion
under those conditions and
um so that's one possibility
the alternative
is that there's got to be
this goes back again to the ancient
greeks but it's also
piaget a lot of folks thought no there's
there's got to be something because you
can't
in order to understand piaget claimed
anything
you have to be able to connect it to
something that you quote already know
so if there's not at least some implicit
knowledge including knowledge of
ourselves
then there'd be nothing upon which to
construct a self or phenomenological
view of the world
so i'm dodging your question because i a
very diplomatic answer no yeah well yeah
because i i
think i could see it both ways and uh
and some of the people that i've been
like
struggling with like philosophers like
i've been trying to understand
martin heidegger for the past couple of
years and
i i think these guys do a great job
better than me of
of ops few skating and dodging
those questions with thousand page books
not just
two minutes uh of verbal gymnastics
no that that is um
actually one of the the finest questions
i i would
i would say though just based on some of
the things that
i've been reading lately uh there's a
book by
a famous guy he's a primatologist
michael tomasello
at the max planck institute in germany
it's called becoming human
and i think that a human being raised
under those conditions
would be pretty much like a great ape
and that is that
would be able to learn from experience
might even be able to learn from
observing
somebody else doing something uh
but the way that tomasello puts it is
that
in the absence of the capacity to have
joint attention with another human which
the
the robot couldn't do that that you
can't get to the next step
which he claims um is the prerequisite
for the kind of awareness that
ultimately distinguishes us as human
so the denial of death the awareness of
death as you said at the beginning i
love that
kind of spectrum that we had of or at
one end and dread at the other i didn't
realize
until this conversation that that was
the way it works but it totally is
the ability for us to see beauty to look
at the night sky feel
insignificant you know go on a walk and
pick up a leaf and
sort of marvel at its beauty is matched
only by our ability to be completely
terrified at the fact that one day it's
all going to end that's that
the poet rilke walking with who is he
walking with and he starts crying
oh well not nature young
crying because he's terrified he's
terrified of the fact that this is all
going to end
um yes but you can't have it both ways
so no you know
you know it you have to be able to
accept the dread side in order to
maximally appreciate the awe yes
so the denial of death or the awareness
of death is inbuilt into us as humans
and yet if i was baby with robot
and i never saw anyone die would i know
that i could die would i be fearful of
death
yeah no so that uh you would be
uh indifferent in the only situation
one might claim would be uh in the
immediate
proximity to mortal danger
in which case you'd have the same fight
and flight reaction of an antelope being
attacked by a lion
so there's some there's some things that
are so hard wired into us but
absolutely what we're talking about here
especially with death
is the ability to
consciously rearrange
that innate that innate
uh sympathetic response
and then create persona and narrative
and you know all of the all of the
ridiculous extraneous stuff that we do
that we do
that we totally don't need um that's it
you got it
oh my goodness okay i dude we are we're
gonna have to
do this again sometime mate because i've
just got a million different things and
the audience is gonna have them as well
um before we finish up a couple of
couple of quick
quicker fire ones what does tranquilize
yourself with the trivial mean
i love that so that's a kierkegaard
phrase that heidegger
also picks up on and uh
his point is that the average individual
and heidegger is quite clear when he
says that this is not meant
pejoratively even though it sounds like
it
because the argument is that we all do
this sometimes
but what what heidegger said is that in
response to death anxiety
most people just unconsciously and
[Music]
self-reflectively
they just literally desperately embrace
the social role that is afforded to them
in the context of their culture and
they essentially become culturally
constructed meat puppets
uh who live their lives um
as caricatures of a stereotype of their
particular
social role and kierkegaard's point
is that when you do that you just
tranquilize yourself uh with the
trivial um the most
popular event in the united states every
year
is the super bowl and so
uh you know watching football the stupid
kind of football
and eating chicken wings and shopping
more people go shopping in the u.s after
thanksgiving
the day after thanksgiving than who vote
in presidential elections and so crazy
it's crazy and so
shocking and uh and so that's why frank
zappa dead musician
he says the average american treats
intelligent behaviors if it was some
kind of a hideous physical deformity
and he's right and so and then heidegger
comes along
and he's like yeah okay uh that's one
kind
of of tranquilizing you know where
you're sitting at home
you know just pounding beer and watching
the telly
but there's another kind of
tranquilization
and that's just frenetic activity where
you just
keep yourself so busy
superficially engaged in the vagaries of
life
that you appear to be there's a veneer
of things going well but
you're actually an empty husk
uh desperately keeping busy so you don't
sit still long enough
to think about the fact that you might
not be fully satisfied
do you know woody allen's film uh annie
hall no
okay so you're too young and so i won't
go there because there's a scene
that makes reference to the denial of
death that
illustrates that point but so those are
the two kinds
of being tranquilized you know just
being passive
you know and and being surrounded uh by
trivia and stuff or you know being
active in one's pursuit
of the uninspired and unimportant
i think i've been playing around with
these ideas for a little while um
one thing i've noticed and i'm a massive
advocate for people being as
weird as they can possibly be i.e um
compromising as little of
themselves for society as as is possible
because i think
what that leads to is you um
not actually being able to work out what
your own truth is i wonder
whether or not the fact that most people
the broad cross section of society
prefers people that they can fit into
easily defined archetypal roles
is because those people don't force them
to step out of that
particular um that's the geek that's the
nerd that's this maiden that's the
redeemed that's the villain that's the
whatever
um i wonder whether that plays into what
you're talking about and i also think
that the current self-development
movement
this kind of i'm you know i'm
contributing to it although i hope that
i'm doing it in a slightly more virtuous
way
but the the motivational speaker you can
become
anything you want movement at the moment
i think also
is the 21st century much
more cerebral manifestation of
just what would have been the industry
of
religious speakers back in the day that
this is you being able to transcend what
is going on but it's repurposed and
repackaged into
words that have a para scientific a
perry scientific sort of uh
tinge to them which removes the
criticism the easy sort of low-hanging
fruit criticism
and the ickiness that religion has had
and theology's kind of gotten now in a
scientific society
but still serves exactly the same reason
that
you can become anything you want you can
be more productive do more in your day
well why do you want to do more in your
day well if i do more in my day i get
more life before it
dot dot inevitably ends there you go
i there's an african proverb that i like
it's just give us
life life more life
i love how you put it and i also love
the distinction that you
just made between trying to help people
make the most of themselves in a
virtuous sense
which you surely are and
um becoming a 21st
century essentially
a guru of sorts
who is no different than a charismatic
political leader to the extent that
you're exploiting people's
anxieties and insecurities for your own
personal gain
well it's it's weaponizing it isn't it
and commodities that's the reason for it
it is and so i think we um
for what it's worth i think what you
and like-minded compatriots are doing
is is honestly the way of the world i
mean i'm an egghead researcher i'm proud
of the work that i do
i've written books i write journal
articles that are non-pharmacological
interventions for insomnia
um uh you know i we write stuff and
maybe 12
people on earth or partake of it
you said that you learned of my
ideas uh from uh talking to lex
and i i enjoyed talking to him immensely
um there have been more people
who i have exchanged ideas with
in the last six weeks than i have in the
last six years
for two reasons one is is that this is a
much more
effective medium for the dissemination
of ideas
and and the second is this is
we are uber social creatures who come to
know
ourselves in the context of uh
sincere conversations with others that's
one of the things that i like about
heidegger even though he was a nazi is
that
he emphasized the incredibly important
role
of language and discourse and
if there's a hope for humankind uh
the way i see it it's going to be a
proliferation
of people uh that
are doing what you're doing
in the various manifestations or
incarnations i think it gives me great
hope
yeah me too i think that um
what's interesting is is a lot of people
i think are drawn to these sort of
longer form
reflective introspective conversations
uh because maybe they're hungry for them
elsewhere they don't
they can't talk to their brother or
sister or friends about it because that
doesn't feel very natural
and the bizarre thing is that upon us
now having a platform
and a communications network which
permits us to do this globally
you realize that the solitude and the
weirdness that you thought was a
personal affliction your whole life is
actually very
commonplace and you're an incredibly
good company there you go but again you
just made a
a you made an earth shattering point and
a guy named
c wright mills in a book called the
power elite
written in the 1950s he made the same
point and that's that
most of us and hannah arendt made this
point in her book about fascism and that
is that
uh that what that what makes a society
ripe for fascism is that if everybody
feels isolated
and and has a sense or that nobody
shares their problems
and there's nothing more uplifting even
if it's painful
than to recognize that what you might
have been attributed
to yourself as your own personal malady
uh is a uh more common than you think
and b may not be due to your own
uh weaknesses as an individual but
rather as the inevitable
result of structural inequalities built
into
uh you know macro institutional systems
and so i think there's a lot to be
gained
from these kinds of pursuits absolutely
and the other thing as well is
that weirdness and uniqueness is your
competitive advantage
even you know if i need to say again to
the people who are listening
it might not feel like it but you should
view
the particular quirks that you have
as competitive advantages in the same
way as as soon as you can flip a workout
from when it hurts this is bad to when
it hurts i lean into discomfort because
that's what i'm here for
if you view your weirdness your
uniqueness the particular
peculiars that you have the lisp the
slight the the the offset
hips the pain in your back the you know
the good looks the bad looks the traumas
all of that stuff if you
purpose them toward okay that makes me
more interesting that makes me more
unique that makes me less of the
archetypal stereotypical caricature that
i
could be if i decide to nerf the edges
and
round off the corners of my life that's
not the way it is and i i can say from
personal experience
that upon embracing all of the weird
weird and wonderful elements of my life
that i have my life has got linearly or
exponentially better
from then until now and sheldon i know
that you have to dash off mate um i i
feel like we could go on for much longer
and
are really keen to get you back um if
people want to find out more about
yourself
where should they go uh they should um
go
to uh the internet and uh
look me up at skidmore college which is
in saratoga springs new york
or just email me s solomon
s-s-o-l-o-m-o-n
at skidmore.edu some i'm kind of third
world i don't have a website or
twitter uh but i do answer email and i
welcome
uh questions and love exchanging ideas
and um i do appreciate all of this chris
and so i i
sincerely hope that this is the
beginning of an ongoing
exchange of ideas i thought this was
great
thank you me too final final final
question let's say someone wants to get
into
some of the stuff that we've spoken
about today you must have
name dropped 20 plus authors who is an
accessible what is an accessible book
that someone can grow
okay at the risk of being
self-promoting get it out there sean get
it out there
i would say uh that ernest becker's the
denial of death or
another book called the birth and death
of meaning are
where we got our ideas from uh but a lot
of folks
uh find that to be difficult um
we wrote a book called the worm at the
core um
on the role of death in life
and it was our desire uh to
uh present these ideas in a
conversational manner and
so uh anybody that might want to
just get introduced to these notions
um i would suggest that um and i
don't like selling things um if you
happen to go buy
our book um that's fine if five more
people
buy it i'll be able to buy shoes um
anybody that wants
to see our book um if you just email me
i'd be happy to send you a pdf file of
the book so i don't want to appear to be
shelling for
anything people that are listening if
they've enjoyed today the amazon link
to worm in the call will be in the show
notes below go and check it out
um like i say sheldon i'm really really
excited to get you back on hopefully
this is the beginning
of a uh of a burgeoning friendship
between us but for now mate thank you so
much
uh very much so for me too and thanks
chris and we'll talk again soon
[Music]